it's a pftpm podcast change of venue a
little too toasty out to be in the barn
we've got an air conditioner there but
it's loud and it doesn't quite do the
job so i'm in my office i don't think
i've ever done this from my office
before i did the dp show the other day
so this is the location this is where i
work all the time i cleared all the crap
out of the way forced me to clean my
office we'll keep my office clean if
this becomes a new semi location for the
pfdpm podcast i know some of you have
been agitating for the podcast and i
apologize i haven't done them more
frequently
it's been busier
working on the website cranking out
content in recent weeks than i thought
it would be this is supposed to be the
slow time and i thought it would be even
slower than usual this year with no
real off-season programs with
limited media access although plenty of
teams are doing a good job making
players team
and coaches available but with the
seismic changes that are happening in
society and how that spilled over to the
nfl it has made things busier than
anticipated in june of 2020 but that's
okay i like having plenty to do i just
haven't had time to do the podcast we're
doing it today and it's questions
only no guests no pre-ordained topics
although i may i may from time to time
deviate into some other topic depending
upon what a question makes me think of
and i'm going to get started as i always
do at the top of the stack
the ftp and posse since i follow that
account the questions that he posts end
up on top and this one comes via the pft
pm posse from
og tom g post
what about teams sequestering together
during the week
and only being allowed home on weekends
after their families have been tested as
well makes for a long season but would
significantly reduce the risk of
infection and the number of tests all
right
this question flows from comments made
by dr anthony fauci regarding the
possibility or his opinion or whatever
it may be
that the nfl won't be able to
play this season
without utilizing the bubble concept
that we're going to see from the nba in
orlando now there are concerns about dr
fauci because from time to time it does
seem like he's a little bit all over the
map and also
he's the guy that has become
faces of inconvenience and at some point
people were bound to be
annoyed with the things he's saying
because he's telling us things we don't
want to hear we don't like the people
who tell us the things we don't want to
hear we like the people who tell us the
things we want to hear a lot of times
growing up between your mom and your dad
you end up liking the parent that gives
you all the stuff you want and not
liking the parent as much who imposes
the discipline that's kind of the way it
goes it's human nature and dr fauci has
become as far as the government is
concerned the parent that is always
telling you what you need to do
and from time to time it does annoy
people but
we probably should listen to him and we
probably should heed his advice and his
opinions and even without his advice and
his opinions there's been kind of a
sense in recent weeks
that
this thing could go off the rails by the
time we get to september october
november especially because of the way
we see the virus increasing and the
cases increasing and the the warnings
becoming more dire in some states that
we thought were in the clear and that
they thought they had everything under
control and
you know the reality is there's a virus
out there that is not going to all of a
sudden decide
to declare victory and retreat so
i
as a preliminary matter
don't necessarily disagree with dr
fauci's assessment that it would be very
difficult to have an nfl season without
a bubble concept but i also think
that a bubble concept is going to be
very very difficult to accomplish
especially with 32 nfl franchises and 53
players per roster plus practice squads
that could be as large as 16. that's a
lot of people when you throw in the
coaches and the other essential
personnel that's a lot of people to say
you have to essentially
surrender your life for the next four or
five months
stay within a very contained
environment
and oh by the way if it sounds familiar
remember when i mentioned that as a
possibility taking everyone to area 51
or the greenbrier in west virginia or
somewhere building basically a dormitory
or barracks and having enough fields
there and just doing it all in a
self-contained world
that is free from and insulated from the
virus and people thought how crazy that
was well that may be the only way to do
it
and if you're not willing to do it if
you can't pull that off and i think it
would be very hard to pull off then you
don't have football season i mean that
that's the thing there's a point where
the nfl may have to ask itself are we
willing to do something that would be so
extreme
to allow football season to happen
and would we choose that over just not
having football season so that's where
this question comes from it is an
outgrowth of this possibility as raised
by dr falchi that the nfl may have to go
with a bubble approach in order to get
the season in
now
keeping the teams together all week long
and then they see families on the
weekends we play games on the weekend so
i think you would have like a tuesday
wednesday maybe where you would be with
your family but yeah your family's gonna
have to be tested as well and if your
family now where is your family where
are you do you sequester each team in
its own community is it like mini
bubbles where the players are kept away
from everyone else but you have 32
independent bubbles or do you just have
a location where all of the teams go and
they stay there and there's no travel
there's no flying there's no anything
there's no intermingling with the
population i don't know again once we
start going down this path we see how
complicated it is like everything else
related to the virus in the nfl you
answer a question five more questions
pop up and you answer those five
questions and five more
questions pop up and it continues until
it mushrooms out of control that could
happen and i've been saying for a while
now especially after last week when the
nfl number one sends out a protocol that
seems very very restrictive and
unrealistic when juxtaposed against
eventually you have to go out on a
football field that plus the nfl pa
saying we never
agreed to any of this plus john harbaugh
the coach of the ravens saying it's
humanly impossible to comply i don't
have a great feeling i don't have a
significant degree of confidence that
the nfl
has or will have the right kind of plan
in place all that said look i like the
creativity i just don't think this is
practical either i think that the
ultimate solution the best solution
short of a bubble and i don't think the
bubble will work you need to have
basically an airlock at every facility
where you enter you get tested every
time you show up
every time you go through the doors to
the facility you get tested if you're
negative you proceed if you're positive
you get
you get
moved toward whatever the quarantine
protocol is and i think you get tested
on the way in and i think it's socially
responsible to get tested on the way out
so there isn't somebody who's become
positive in the 12 hours that he or she
has been at the facility and is leaving
and going back into the community so
test on the way in test on the way out
and the key is having the right kind of
testing technology
so that when the test is implemented you
get a quick result it's a reliable
result and it reflects whether or not
the person's positive if you have it
you're positive if you don't you're
negative i've heard two or three tests
per week
look here's what we're trying to avoid
we're trying to avoid a person who is
positive and shedding viruses they say
it sounds very graphic but and it's just
kind of gross if someone is shedding
virus you don't want that person going
out onto a practice field or into a game
and infecting multiple people how do you
ensure that doesn't happen now you
ideally don't even want them in the
facility if they're shedding virus but
within the facility it looks like there
will be some effort to maintain at least
six feet of distance and masks and
arrows like when you go to the store now
and you're like a
rat in a maze looking for the cheese and
you're following the arrows around
that may help
but
when you get to the point where you go
into a practice field or into a game
that's when it goes out the window you
can't have somebody positive in that
setting unless they're designing
hazmat suits that will wrap around the
uniform it's going to be pretty hard to
play football and i think people start
to realize that now it's gonna be pretty
hard to play football
if there's any chance that one person in
that 22-man scrum is positive for the
virus so
look long answer
bearable
as of right now
i'm having a hard time feeling
optimistic about the nfl figuring out
everything it has to figure out
especially because there hasn't been
much of an effort to get us
informed and us to buy in and maybe they
don't care at some point they need to
care at some point they need to
do and say something more than we plan
to play the full season to get people to
say
i think they have a plan to play the
full season that is practical that works
and that takes into account the
realities of the virus and when i hear
dr fauci say what he said and i see the
response that was issued by dr alan
sills the nfl's chief medical officer i
look at it and i say
man
i just think it's an uphill fight and i
hope they pull it off
i want football
anytime these issues come up you're
rooting against football i'm not rooting
against football i am rooting for
football and i'm trying to make sure
that everyone who is in a position to
resolve these issues is thinking about
these issues and coming up with the
appropriate solutions pft pm posse
the posse started conversing with my
nephew anthony zieg who does tremendous
design work working on making some posse
shirts would you let him
put pft and pftpm shirts on his etsy so
we can buy them from him how is that a
question for the mailbag
well i i suppose i don't know i got to
talk to him about whether he even wants
to do it i i you know
if there's going to be a revenue stream
here i'd kind of like to get a little
you know i'd like to i'd like to get a
little taste of it myself there pftp and
policy you're trying to keep money off
my my uh account here you're trying to
keep food off my plate i'm kidding i
will probably do something like that i
don't know that we do pft pm often
enough to justify the t-shirts there's a
push like two years ago when we did this
more often and maybe at some point we
will do it more often maybe once the
world returns to semi-normal we will do
it more often so i'll take it under
advisement like so many other things but
typically you know what it means when i
take something under advisement it's
like the nfl tabling a proposal until
may i'll take it under advisement
indefinitely which means we may never
hear from it again we know nfl owners
are going to cut costs somewhere
if the players don't and they shouldn't
accept a pay cut where is that likely to
be and will have a negative impact on
player health and safety for example
cutting medical training rehab staff
here's what i think is going to happen
if the players refuse as they should to
any type of a give back approach and
under the cba there's nothing in there
that requires players to reduce salaries
for this year even if they lose games
this year the cba has a provision
that triggers an obligation to sit down
and negotiate future salary caps if
games are cancelled this year and it's
kind of redundant because they negotiate
the salary cap every year but that's the
only thing in there that's the only
thing remotely resembling a forced major
clause in the cba so
if the
league approaches the union and says we
want to cut 10 percent
off the board we want everyone to take a
10 reduction in the salary they're
supposed to make this year that means
for example dak prescott if he doesn't
sign a long-term contract 31.4 million
you take away 3.14 million from him if
you're supposed to make 5 million you
take away 500 000 you you can
you can do the math for the most part
point is if the players say no what
happens
i'm concerned what will happen is at
that point the teams will identify
middle class players guys making three
four five million dollars a year guys
who otherwise would be at risk of a late
august hey we want you to take a pay cut
and if you don't we're going to cut you
and if we cut you no one else is going
to sign you because everybody's got
their rosters set so you're pretty much
screwed so you better take the pay cut
that happens all the time i think you'll
be more aggressive with that they may
not even negotiate the pay cut they may
just cut the guy gone boom and i think
that's who's at risk and when you couple
that with what i've heard about some
teams being inclined to take only 75 or
80 guys to camp well who are the 10 or
15 you get rid of before you go to camp
is it it's not draft picks is it
undrafted free agents that you may have
you know under con well that you do have
under contract at very cheap amounts you
just get rid of them who do you get rid
of and i think that people who will be
at jeopardy if they do take fewer than
90 players to camp or when it's time to
go to week one of the regular season
when veteran salaries become as a
practical matter guaranteed that's when
i think some of these middle class guys
may have to worry and what the nflpa
needs to do
need to watch this very carefully if
they do indeed tell the league pound
sand or salt or whichever the right word
is i never know the nflpa needs to make
sure that for example there isn't a
coordinated effort by all teams to trim
ten percent of their anticipated salary
budget for the season and some teams get
rid of three or four guys some teams get
rid of one or two whatever if the total
amount is they all cut about 10 of what
they were otherwise due to pay
it's gonna look a little bit like
coordination which is collusion which is
illegal under the cba 32 distinct
businesses under the labor deal are able
to do the things that the cva allows
them to do by way of decision making
when it comes to their roster and
whatnot but you can't
you can't do something
like
what i just laid out if you go to the
players and say we want you to cut ten
percent they say no and they all agree
hey you know what we're gonna win point
nod nod we're all gonna cut 10 off of
our salaries and let's all do it so no
one is at any type of a disadvantage
moving forward all right next question
pftp and policy important question what
have you had on the grill lately what
activities have you been doing to keep
yourself occupied
why have you started getting haircuts
again not judging are there minimal
covet cases in your area are you taking
extra safety precautions etc that is
quite a long question there let me begin
with the grill
i here's what i and this dovetails with
another part of it i go to the store
maybe once a week and i wear a mask and
i try not to act judgy
of the people who are there without
masks i try to be very
look straight ahead
no facial expressions it helps when most
of your faces are covered by a mask
which for me is an improvement
i get pissed off though
when i sense a vibe from someone who
isn't wearing a mask
by seeing someone else in a mask they
they're made to feel like maybe they
should be wearing a mask so they get
pissed off the person who's wearing the
mask and i detect that from time to time
and haven't said anything yet and i
probably won't
but man i get irritated by that like
don't get mad at me because i'm doing
the right thing and reminding you that
you're not doing the right thing that
you're not being considerate of your
fellow man that you're not protecting
yourself or anyone else because you
insist on walking around without a mask
on so anyway i'll go to the store once a
week i got a mask that i wear
one day i had my sunglasses on and the
mask and it's a black mask and it's like
i i walked in and i realized i had the
sunglasses on i mean there's a certain
point where they think you're gonna rob
the place the combination of the mask
and the sunglasses pretty close to
looking like a guy who's intent on
robbing the place especially when the
mask is black so anyway go to kroger
local grocery store they have excellent
steak if you live near a kroger and i
can't vouch for the the meat department
and other krogers the meat department
here has excellent steaks so rib eyes
fillets once or twice a week i'll make
some and whatever's left over gets put
you know in tupperware and gets thrown
back on the grill or even in the
microwave it's awesome it's awesome i
use the
mccormick montreal steak seasoning
liberally applied to each side try to do
a couple of minutes on each side on
fairly high heat the rib eyes quick cook
quickly the rib for the
fillets take a little bit longer but
that's what i've been doing on the grill
although we had we had
should be ashamed to admit this we
haven't made hot dogs the other night we
had hot dogs in a while holy crap
a very well grilled hot dog is just
absolutely excellent we go with nathan's
hot dogs by the way uh tasty very tasty
no no endorsement they're not getting
paid i i'm disgusted by the the hot dog
eating contest so i probably should eat
hot dogs other than nathan's i should be
anti-nathan's either way the nathan's
hot dog is pretty good
uh what was the rest of this question
what have i been doing to keep myself
occupied i just work all the time i if
you haven't noticed i i work all the
time i still won't work out an hour a
day i play madden while i work out on
the exercise bike my ultimate team is up
to a 97 97 and a half i'm going 97 and a
half because the defense is a 98 the
offense is in 97. uh after we're done
here i'll go down and get my hour in i
get an hour at about 27 miles an hour i
don't stop until i get my 27 miles and
650 calories burned and then at night
i'll work outside i've got some other
projects i'm working on that we'll
discuss at some point at the appropriate
point some other writing projects that i
kind of have in the hopper two of them
by the way but uh most of the time i'm
working on the website planning the show
for the next day whatever the case may
be and i've just stayed here you know
we've had family over and we have a
large patio so we separate out there we
do that once a week or so have everybody
over for dinner very careful about
keeping our distance we had a night
where i had some friends over and we
watched the ufc fights we took a tv out
and put it on the patio and kept our
distance and you know so my life hasn't
been all that much different because i
really don't go anywhere anyway i think
kyle murray said that recently for him
none of this has been much of a change
because he really doesn't do anything
it's kind of how it is for me i go to
the store once a week now i had a long
stretch where i didn't go out at all
like 35 days but about once a week i go
out and ask for the haircuts
right before the lockdown i got a
haircut
my
my longtime barber who still works at a
different job no longer cuts hair i got
him to come over to the house and he
gave me a haircut and then it got really
really long but then once they started
to
reduce the
restrictions here in west virginia i had
him come back we did the mask we kept
our distance we did you know it was very
very safe that was several weeks ago and
then this past weekend the place where
i'd currently get my haircut it was
their first day back
and i was able to finagle early access
before it was even open so i went in
before they open on their first day back
and got my haircut then and we'll see
how it goes from here the the cases in
west virginia have been going up they
haven't been rampant here but they have
been going up i have a friend
who recently was diagnosed with
coronavirus and he was here a couple of
weeks before he was diagnosed for a
little get together we had out on the
patio and it happens it's nothing to be
ashamed of people are going to get it
it's an invisible virus that is
airborne that is potent and that
it happens and
i'm just hopeful i can avoid it for as
long as i can i don't know how it's
going to go this season if there is
football and i hope there is traveling
back and forth to connecticut maybe
we'll all be doing the football night in
america show from home studios i don't
know if that's the case i already got
one so it's not going to be a pain in
the butt for me to get one ready but
we'll see how that all plays out and and
the virus is the thing that is going to
control all of this end of the day the
virus is in charge all we can do is
react to it rob foster 135 i'd really
like to hear sims evaluation of his
father versus terry bradshaw i don't
know i mean they really didn't play at
the same time like sims versus jill
montana would make more sense
i don't terry bradshaw's just kind of a
random name in this context because they
were from not different eras but
different decades when they were
prominent but uh i don't know
if i remember i'll ask sims to give me
an evaluation that i can pass along to
you of
phil sims versus terry bradshaw
robert block 07 how do you explain your
ridiculous hypocrisy here we go of
championing the limit to spread
covet
march 19 article on sean payton while
not being critical of players
participating in large public gatherings
when team facilities were closed due to
health concerns of the ongoing pandemic
what large public gatherings are you
talking about what are we talking about
and and here's the thing
early on
early on in the process i was very
vigilant about pointing out that states
were on lockdown but players were doing
things that violated the lockdown you're
supposed to stay at home you're out
working out all touching the same
football posing together for pictures it
was clearly violating the local orders
and people went nuts people jumped my my
stuff for i'm trying not to curse so
matt casey doesn't have to worry about
bleeping anything but
i and it was stunning to me it was like
people and
that was the first time and i remember
telling my wife you know what's going to
happen eventually there's going to be a
revolt against these restrictions and
people are just going to act like they
never existed and they're just going to
go back to living their lives and their
attitude is going to be screw this we
don't want to do this anymore because
i'm getting resistance for pointing out
that people are doing things that are
irresponsible that may spread the virus
so fine you want to do irresponsible
things and spread the virus go ahead i'm
going to continue to be careful others
are going to continue to be careful i
mean if it's and this is where
we need to understand the difference
between
assuming a risk of something that only
affects you
versus assuming a risk of behavior that
can affect you and also other people
this isn't
the equivalent of driving a motorcycle
without a helmet when you drive a
motorcycle without a helmet you are
risking serious injury or death to you
when
you participate in any type of activity
that is contrary to what we've been
advised to do as it relates to the virus
you're putting others at risk because
if you catch it
before you know you have it
or if you're one of the ones one of the
many who never know they have it
what happens
you potentially give it to someone else
and they give it to someone else and so
on and so on until grandma or grandpa
are dead
that's the key distinction
you're participating in the conveyance
of a virus that eventually will kill
either your grandma or grandpa or
someone else's grandma or grandpa or
your diabetic cousin or brother or
nephew or niece or aunt or uncle or
someone else's
that's the difference here this isn't
hey
i'm willing to take the risk that i'm
going to get it i'm young i'm healthy i
want to have fun i want to do my thing
you're participating in the potential
spread of something that has already
killed 120 000 people and they're
projecting 200 000 now by october
and
it's one thing to look at those numbers
and say wow that's a lot and you know
one of the arguments i see and this
well you know 7 500 people died of other
stuff today like that that makes it okay
there are deaths that are going to
happen
for reasons that are not preventable and
then there are the deaths that will
happen for a preventable reason and this
virus
it's preventable if people just do what
they're supposed to do
in theory no one has to get it in theory
no one has to die from it
you know i i
have a very strict policy when it
relates to lightning
and i follow the guidelines that are out
there if you if you hear thunder you can
be hit by lightning so if i'm outside
and i hear thunder i get my ass inside
and yeah oh it's it's it's way off in
the distance it's like look
anybody that was ever hit by lightning
outside and died from it could have
avoided it if they had just gotten their
asses inside it's that simple it's a
preventable death these viral deaths are
preventable so don't give me this well
you know 7 500 people died today of
other reasons that's fine but a thousand
died today of the coronavirus or
whatever the number is and
it's
i don't
i really do believe that there will be a
special place in hell
for the people who have been
deliberately pandering to the human
nature
that is out there among so many people
to find a reason to not take the virus
seriously and that's what some of these
folks in the media don't realize
by giving them a reason to feel okay
with the choices they're making and the
lifestyle they're leading you're
contributing to the spread of the virus
you're contributing to people getting
sick you're contributing to people dying
by encouraging that behavior their blood
is on your hands and as i said i hope
there's a special place in hell for
these people who are
deliberately
in attempt to profit from it by
pandering to the people who want to hear
it it gets back to what i was saying
earlier dr fauci is the parent that
disciplines you and then these people in
the media are the parent who will give
you a cookie no matter what even when
the last thing you need is a cookie and
you go to it's that simple folks don't
you understand how you're being
manipulated here
there are people out there in the media
today who are deliberately saying things
that those people who want
very much to be able to live in the
blissful ignorance of the pandemic
allowing themselves to say
i'm right to do what i'm doing i'm
justified to do what i'm doing and thank
you for being a voice in the media that
doesn't make me feel guilty about
behaviors about which i should feel
guilty so the people who are pushing
that stuff like i said
special place in hell
at uh
hopefully i won't be any hope hopefully
i won't be around to inspect whatever
special place in hell that may be
so there's the answer to your question
robert bloch
look and and and i think that this why
haven't i been critical of players
participating in large public gatherings
i think that's code for why aren't you
saying that people shouldn't be out
participating in the protest and this is
one thing i've been meaning to say and i
think sims and i mentioned this the
other day on pft live
there's a fundamental difference between
participating in protests that
organically arose from outrage over
decades if not centuries of social
inequality manifested by the 8 minute
and 40 second 46 second murder of george
floyd and people feeling compelled to
participate in those protests because
they feel that that is a bigger issue
than what may happen to them if they get
coronavirus or pass along to someone
else and it's really it's just a
visceral i must go out and participate
in these protests that's far different
than saying well you know what i really
do need to go to kid rock's nightclub
and be young and have fun and drink
pepsi and not wear a mask and and that's
one of the big differences you look at
that photo from over the weekend from
the nashville club the kid rock club
try to find anyone wearing a mask
it's tougher than finding waldo
now you look at protests a lot of people
have masks on so
there's a fundamental difference between
people who took a stand
for what they believe is right and went
out into the streets despite the very
real concerns about the virus and those
who are deliberately choosing to engage
in selfish behaviors
aided and abetted by the
charlatans in the media who are
deliberately telling them what they know
they want to hear
in order to curry their favor get their
traffic and make money off of them and
hopefully you make your money off of
them before they die
alright
charles cz wald
uh
clarified the point and
basically explained what robert block
was getting at organic and long overdue
protests are okay but a private party is
the problem and now robert block says
i'm a hypocrite here we go washington
should change its name because one
person is genuinely offended yet during
the anthem is okay even though many
people are offended because they
incorrectly find the display to be
disrespectful let's talk about that for
a second
first of all it's far more than one
person that's offended by the washington
nickname which is a dictionary defined
slur by the way you know people ask me
what about chiefs should chiefs go too
it's like well you know what chiefs
isn't a dictionary to
define slur
the washington team name is so let's
just focus on that you know i don't know
where the line ultimately is
but
let's just start with the one that's
clearly on the wrong side of it now with
chiefs i think the issues are more
subtle like a white guy from topeka
wearing a headdress and war paint
probably not the best thing to do
the war chant probably not the best
thing to do shouting chiefs
at the tail end of the anthem for a
variety of reasons probably not the best
thing to do so if anything robert block
07
who probably should be blocked 07
the hypocrisy is in the people who
refuse to understand why people are
kneeling who refuse to understand that
it is an effort to send a message about
a social injustice that needs to end but
insist on
carrying forward with a dictionary
defined slur that definitely offends
native americans and see the washington
franchise hides behind and this is their
knee-jerk reaction the washington post
poll from 2016 90 of self-identifying
native americans say they're not
offended well 10 are and to me that
should be enough 10 should be enough
now i don't know maybe it takes 20 maybe
it takes 25 maybe it takes 30. i don't
know but the other problem is and we've
written about this and you can find the
stories at pft that poll is flawed okay
self-identifying native americans may
not be native americans they may not be
isn't that one of the big issues that
was kind of hovering in the campaign
somebody who was self-identifying as
native american and there was some other
politician who was and still is using a
pejorative nickname to make fun of the
other politician who self-identifies as
native american but may not be it's not
about who self-identifies as native
american it's about the people who truly
are native american the people who are
involved in tribal practices what do
they think about it i mention that
because
we have written about and spoken about a
study from cal berkeley
that focused on people who are not just
self-identifying but practicing genuine
native americans and the percentage
there of the people deeply insulted
by nicknames like the washington
franchise dramatically higher and the
more involved you are in tribal
practices the higher the percentage of
offense so
don't try to link
the notion that
some are saying the washington franchise
name should change with people saying
well i don't care what you say i still
find it offensive if you kneel during
the anthem if anything the flip side is
what should be true the people who are
kneeling during the anthem have a reason
for it and you should respect that
reason for it and respect their ability
as citizens of the united states to do
whatever they want
during the national anthem this is still
a free country this is not the 11th
commandment thou shalt stand for the
national anthem
and i said this earlier today i think on
either on the show or on pftot i can't
remember
but
the whole idea that we must stand for
the anthem and worship the flag is
antithetical to what america stands for
our freedom includes the freedom to not
stand for the anthem
it includes the freedom to be
at the
at the hot dog counter not paying
attention oblivious to the anthem it
includes the freedom to be in our phones
looking down oblivious to the anthem it
includes the power to have your hat on
oblivious to the rules during the anthem
it includes
all the people out there who do things
during the anthem without a reason i
mean what's worse
using the anthem
as
a conscious
platform
for bringing attention
to a serious social injustice or just
kind of having your head up your ass and
doing whatever standing in line at the
bathroom talking to somebody yucking it
up joking around and not stopping
everything you're doing and and
providing that that song and that that
exercise the reverence it deserves i
hear thunder at least i'm inside but
there's a chance we've lost power like
three times the last two days so there's
a chance it's going to abruptly end like
the finale of the sopranos and some of
you may think hey maybe he got whacked
and maybe you'll be happy about that but
if the screen goes black
if the screen goes black first of all i
did not order onion rings second of all
there's no one in a member's only jacket
in my house that i know of and third of
all i hope to god i'm not dead but
there's a chance i may be and based upon
some of the reactions on twitter in
recent weeks plenty of you will be happy
i want to address that too
um
there are people out there in the media
who think that twitter
is
this
bastion of left-wing thinking i'd sure
like to find those people
because i'll tell you what
all i've seen in reaction to the things
we've been saying and for me it's not an
issue of right or left it's an issue of
right or wrong but the things we've been
saying about social injustice
about fulfilling the promise that is
america to all people all men and women
are created equal life liberty in this
pursuit of happiness equal justice under
law those are the words that are that
are carved into stone above the entry to
the supreme court and in recent days hey
the supreme court has risen above the
political noise
i tell you what
any of the stuff that we tweet
the the the very very strong ultra right
mindset is thriving
on twitter
so
and it's funny to me how and i've seen
this a lot lately well i don't spend a
lot of time on social media but it's
it's uh it's a cauldron of left-wing
ideas well if you don't spend time there
how do you know well you know i never
watch one american news and then people
say that i've never watched it and then
they try to comment on what it is well
how the hell can you comment on what it
is if you've never seen if you don't
know anything about it
people just think it's the flip side of
cnn or msnbc and it's not and it's not
so anyway
it it's just it's amazing to me
how
and i guess it's not amazing because
here's the reality
there is
i had peanuts earlier and i've been
trying i've been dealing with you know
and the problem is when you're on screen
all the time you don't get a break i had
peanuts earl you don't have that one
little piece of peanut that won't get
the hell out of your mouth that one
little piece of peanuts been floating
around for the last 10 minutes it's
finally gone i'm sorry that i had to do
that but the peanut is finally gone
anyway
these media members of the peanut that i
can't get out of my mouth they
understand exactly what they're doing
that's why i refer to so many of them as
dog whistlers they are deliberately
pandering to the trump crowd it's that
simple and there's a lot of people in
the trump crowd and what they try to do
is without ever saying
that
they are part of that mindset or that
they feel that they'll say i'm not
political i'm not political i'm not
political at all and then everything
they say meshes completely with
the political mindset
that caters to the ultra right-wing
crowd it's it's and and they understand
why they're doing it they've decided
look instead of playing it down the
middle
and getting some of the traffic
let's cater to one particular angle and
get all of the traffic and let's just do
that
and when you see what people who
are overtly political in their news and
opinions like a glenn beck or whatever
the case may be how much money they make
that's what it's all about look
i i i'm
i'm saying what i believe my opinion has
been people saying oh you've been very
courageous the past weeks it's not
courageous look there's no there's
nothing courageous about right and wrong
i've been saying what i believe is right
and i don't believe i'm going out on a
limb
to traffic in what i think is clearly
right when it comes to the inequalities
that so many have experienced in this
country for centuries
and the reality is we're all going to be
dead and gone and when i'm gone
and whether it's my grandkids or their
kids or my my
nieces and nephews children and you know
whoever's out there who was related to
me in any way 50 75 100 years from now
and they're doing any type of research
on this crazy turkey time in american
history and hopefully this time stands
out as crazy and turbulent things are a
lot better 75 years from now
i don't want there to be any doubt
as to where the old dead guy who
is decomposing and long since decomposed
in the ravine at the back of his eight
acres
i don't want there to be any doubt about
where i stood on these issues
period that's it i and look i'm not
doing it for money i'm not doing it for
attention i'm doing it because i think
it's right
and
if you don't want to believe that that's
fine oh you're just saying that i'm fine
i can't make you believe me
all i can do is tell you why i'm doing
it and i can tell you that i get
increasingly irritated by the people who
are pandering to a specific segment of
the populace
not believing what they're saying
not believing what they're saying
but sending a clear message blowing that
dog whistle as needed because they
perceive a financial benefit by doing so
and it's it's very similar to the stuff
that's gone on with all the people who
are trying to make folks feel good about
not wearing masks feel good about not
staying home feel good about not
altering anything they're doing
in the
uh climate that we're currently in as it
relates to pandemic all right i haven't
gotten many questions done i've been
going for about 45 minutes here
let's try this one
leapers 500 what is the threshold at
which the season would be called or
canceled when teams lose so many stars
they're uncompetitive players that
refuse the risk i you know what i think
i because i look at it this way
there will be
an endless supply of players who want to
play 1987 players go on strike the nfl
finds 28 rosters full of replacements
like that easy to do right and i think
if anything the nfl should be planning
something like that where as i said this
earlier today on pftot instead of
expanding the practice squads from 12 to
16 you need to have separate rosters
that are you know hugh jackson is
running one and another former coach
jeff fisher is running another one have
four of them there's 32 teams
one for every eight teams not that
they're assigned to those eight teams
but you have these guys who are out
there in four different places
practicing in game shape ready to go
so if there's an outbreak in a given
team and they lose 10 or 15 guys who
test positive on a friday or a saturday
or a sunday morning you can get these
guys in and play the games and i think
the nfl is going to do what it has to do
to play the games
i think they'll be ready to plug in new
players as needed
i think the thing that could really
derail the season is if someone dies
from it if a coach dies if a player dies
if somebody who is close to the action
dies and and let's be realistic about it
apart from the fact that there are
plenty of older coaches
you've got 300 plus pound men morbidly
obese bmi off the chart may maybe
undiagnosed diabetes you know we hear
all the time well hey you know if you
have diabetes just you know you got to
stay inside well there are a lot of
people who don't know they have it
you don't just wake up one day and go
look in the mirror and it says on your
forehead you have diabetes
sometimes it takes a while to come to
the conclusion that that's the reason
you felt like crap for the last x number
of days weeks or months remember when
jay cutler
playing for the broncos
felt like crap all season long losing
weight didn't know what was wrong with
him
eventually somebody decided to give him
a glucose test imagine that imagine that
we draw some blood from this guy and see
whether or not he has diabetes
so
you know it's it's something that people
have without knowing it
and
getting extremely sick or dying from
covet 19 is a hell of a way to find out
that you have diabetes
so
that's what i think the nfl needs to be
concerned about somebody catching it and
somebody dying
you know it's it's the equivalent of if
somebody were to die from a head injury
during a football game what that would
do to football and i remember carson
palmer saying 11 years ago
peter king did a round table of
quarterbacks at the lake tahoe event the
golf event that nbc has every year
and
carson palmer said somebody's eventually
going to die on the field and i remember
that story like exploded when we wrote
about it at pft
and uh somebody's eventually going to
die on the field and you know it hasn't
happened thank god but i think if
somebody would die from covet 19
that would be the thing that would from
a pr standpoint maybe push the nfl
toward pulling the plug and think about
the nba in march
one positive test was all it took to
pull the plug on the nba season now the
nfl has accepted the fact there will be
positive tests the question is
can they keep those positive tests from
becoming serious injury or death and and
look i was led to believe a couple of
months ago and i've yet to go back and
have this conversation now
but that the advances in testing the
advances in treatment will make it
easier for the nfl to pull off football
season and i hope that's right
i hope there's a rapid response test
that's available with saliva or the
prick of a finger and that you can test
everybody every day i just don't think
this two or three times a week is going
to be good enough you've got to be damn
sure before anyone goes out on a
practice field or into a game when the
bodies cannot be kept six feet apart
when the saliva and the droplets and the
blood and the sweat will be commingling
that's when you got to be damn sure that
none of those 22 guys is positive
and there's only one way to do it you
need to be able to test them before
they're in a position where they go out
on the field
we need to be sure they're negative and
it needs to be reliable
and i've heard
that the capacity for those kinds of
tests
is eventually going to be
through the roof there's going to be so
much out there by way of testing it'll
be easy to do and it'll be available and
it'll be daily and that's what they need
without that they're going to have a
hard time keeping that virus out of a
situation where it's going to
potentially spread among players on a
practice field or players on a game
field all right
leapers 500 with what's happening in the
country why is it so hard for some to
understand not every edifice of where
they stand is lost if this progress is
made why is it so hard for some to see
the merits of racial progress that's a
great question this gets back to what i
was talking about earlier
this is a matter of right and wrong
and see what what i think what happened
for a lot of white americans over the
years
when
some specific racial injustice would
happen
we would acknowledge it
we would feel badly about it
and then we would retreat to our bubble
day in and day out
things we have to do raising kids
working jobs doing whatever one day
after another one week after another one
month after another one year after
another we stay in that bubble until the
next time
something like that happens we say it's
horrible and then we go back to the
bubble
with the execution of george floyd in 8
minutes and 45 and 46 seconds captured
on camera
that's the first time in my lifetime
that
that we
didn't go back to the bubble
and that
people who aren't facing that same risk
every time they leave the house
those people continue to be troubled by
what happened and i've seen people push
the statistics well only ex
black males were killed by police in
2019 it doesn't matter
the raw number and thank god it wasn't
more
what matters is
that constant
threat of it happening
that constant presence that constant
fear
that it may happen
that's something that black americans
have that white americans don't have
and how do we get to that point how do
we get to that point is it some
unfounded fear
or is it the product of years and years
and years of inequality of years and
years and years of the people who are
driving a car and get pulled over who
are black being treated differently the
police officer is more leery as he or
she approaches the car more quick to
pull the gun with a black person behind
the wheel than if it's a white person
behind the wheel so i don't know why
this effort
see i think i think what's going on is
this
for those of us who didn't go back to
our bubbles this is welcome
because we feel badly that we've allowed
this we've participated in this see it's
not enough to just say well i don't feel
that way i don't act that way i don't
treat people that way so that's good
enough there's more of an obligation i
think to go beyond that
and to push for others to come to that
same conclusion and for others to behave
the way that we would behave so we have
stayed out of our bubble the problem is
these changes that are being made are
keeping the people who want to stay in
their bubbles in their bubbles their
comfort is being disrupted i saw that
comment recently from i think it was ben
shapiro that he doesn't enjoy sports
anymore not that he looks like a guy
that really enjoys sports anyway but he
doesn't enjoy sports anymore because it
it it robs him of his comfort it
deprives him of his comfort or something
like that see
people don't want to be faced with
things that make them feel guilty that
make them feel bad that make them feel
uncomfortable that and that's why
we here stick to sports when we raise a
topic that comes off as political we
here stick to sports not when it's any
political topic but when it's a topic
that makes someone uncomfortable they
don't want to confront their own beliefs
they don't want to confront their own
behavior and anyone who makes them
confront that
they're making them uncomfortable
they're depriving them of their comfort
stick to sports i don't want you to tell
me that i'm doing something i shouldn't
do i don't want you to tell me that i
may be thinking of things in a way that
i shouldn't i don't want you to tell me
that i should be staying home and not
going out to kidrock's bar without a
mask and pressing myself against a bunch
of other people even if that means
somebody's grandma or grandpa's gonna
die i don't want you telling me that
you're disrupting my comfort
i could say a lot more i think you get
the point
people just don't and it's it's funny
how that term snowflake gets thrown
around
who are the real snowflakes nowadays
who who who are who are really the
snowflakes
have we thought about that
people who can't take
hearing things that disrupt their
comfort
that force them
out of their comfort zone
that force them to consider issues
that maybe they should be considering
behaving in ways that maybe they should
behave
we don't want that we want to stay in
our comfort zone you're making us
uncomfortable how dare you
how dare you make me uncomfortable
how much positive change
comes without some level of discomfort
how much positive change is done easily
if it was easy if it was easy everything
would be exactly where it needs to be
these things aren't easy these things
are difficult
the challenge is to get people to
understand what's right and what's wrong
and the problem arises from
all the efforts
by some in the media
to move the goal posts to change the
topic it's not just media members
there are a lot of people that i've
tried to reason with and once you start
making salient points
the response is well what about this
well what about that well what about
this and deflection deflection
deflection and it's impossible to get
anyone to face the ultimate issue
because they constantly move on to
something else where they're more
comfortable see you're making me
uncomfortable on this point so i'm going
to go to this point instead where i'm
comfortable and then when you make them
uncomfortable on that point they're
going to go over here to this point
where they're more comfortable
and
then they move the goal posts and you
kick the ball through it and you make
them uncomfortable and then they go over
here
it's not progress it's not how to get to
where we need to be
dr j144 hypothetically if players at
oklahoma state banded together and tried
to force oklahoma state to replace mike
gundy with a minority coach would they
be successful i get the general feeling
over the past month that players have
more leverage than they realize with
stuff like this well look
i
i don't know how successful it would be
and i don't know how much leverage they
truly have
because what are your options really
like chuba hubbard
if he didn't want to make nice with mike
gundy and i'm still not sure based on
his demeanor during that video that
everything is fine with chuba hubbard
but
what's he going to do is he going to sit
out all of 2020 and then enter the draft
the nfl is not going to let him into the
supplemental draft over something like
this they don't want to make it easy for
guys to get into the supplemental draft
because they're trying to protect and
preserve the free farm system that is
college football
it's not like he could transfer at this
point
so
if enough players come together though
and there is a revolt
i i
i don't know
could there be a new head it's kind of
late it's you know i think and maybe
this is how mike gundy put out the fire
it's like hey guys there's a damn thing
we can do at this point that's going to
help this team win football games in
2020. so what we can do is find a way to
come together and work together or this
season is going to go down the tubes
and we can worry about these other
issues after the season and you know
what for mike gundy when you look at his
record the past few years he's kind of
limited on the fumes of 2011 when the
team finished number three in the ap
poll winning the fiesta bowl and done a
whole lot since then
hadn't done enough if you're if you're
lincoln riley maybe you can survive some
of this if you're my gundy i'm not sure
you can and it may be that everybody
decides to play nice and hold it all
together for now
to get through the season and then after
the season that's when the uprising will
come you know it doesn't
make much sense to jostle for oklahoma
state to fire mike gundy at a time when
they're just not gonna fire him
in november december especially if they
go at or around 500 again that's the
time to make the stand kind of like what
eric dickerson did with jeff fisher he
attacked jeff fisher at exactly the
right time to get jeff fisher fired near
the end of an unsuccessful season if you
start going after jeff fisher in august
they're not going to do anything about
it in august they're going to wait until
the time comes to fire the guy on the
merits and then it becomes easier to
justify it when there's all this other
stuff they have to deal with all right
let's see what we have here
i'm trying to get through as many of
these as i can
james mcdonough dr j144 if we've been
around long enough to know who sam in
san francisco is do we deserve a twitter
follow from pft
sam francisco in san francisco it's
amazing dr j144 that you remember him
he was a guy who used to call in to the
original digital show when we would take
phone calls and he would read from a
script and he would be just borderline
nervous as he was delivering it in a way
that made it engaging and funny and he
hated frank gore hated frank gore in
fact we had like a phoner that we'd put
up for sam and it would say on there
hates frank gore that's how clear his
hatred of frank gore was i wonder how he
feels about frank gore now and something
happened with the 49ers maybe it was
2014 2013
they ended up
something caused him to kind of
just like not renounce his fan hood of
the 49ers but he stopped calling every
single time we took questions and people
thought it was it was a plant that it
was something no it was just a guy who
called every time so i'm impressed dr
j144 that you remember san francisco and
san francisco i don't know that that's
going to prompt me to follow your
twitter account because i try to only
follow the accounts that i think are
going to give me something that i can
use for the purposes of writing stories
at pft but as always i will take that
under advisement a red zone out an old
school member of the pft posse who was
asking questions long ago
on the digital show will players become
reluctant to report any coronavirus
related symptoms well
yes
and
the protocol that was put out a week and
a half ago by the nfl
it's got a screening procedure questions
that the players get asked every day
do you really think a player is going to
say i don't feel well
when that especially if that player
isn't a player
whose job is guaranteed remember a few
years ago everyone was praising ben
roethlisberger for tapping out of a game
i think it was against the seahawks
because he had concussion symptoms well
he's not going to lose his job to his
backup
but if you're in danger of losing the
job to the backup or if you are the
backup if you're fighting for the job if
you're worried that if you test positive
you're not going to have a job
are you going to walk in and say
you know i don't feel right i haven't
felt right for the past couple of days i
don't think you're going to do that
and i'm telling you folks
i think it would be a horrible mistake
if anyone does it
but i think guys are going to
deliberately expose themselves in june
and july to the virus
so they have the antibodies and they
assume that they're good to go
right there are a lot of people that
just want to get it and be done with it
and they'd rather have it now
in june when nothing's going on then
have it
and develop it during football season
and get shut down for two or three weeks
those guys that are on the fringe to
make the roster
if in august and you're fighting for a
roster spot you're one of the guys
trying to go from 90 to 53
if you get it you're gone for two or
three weeks do you really think you're
making do you think you're making the
team
they're gonna be guys who are tempted to
get it and i think it would be a mistake
because first of all and remember this
anyone out there who's thinking of this
we still don't know for sure
that
if you have had it
you're in the clear and you're not at
risk of getting it again
so
until we know what it conclusively means
to have the antibodies to have already
had the coronavirus
it's it's
it's nothing that's going to give you a
free pass to play for the full season or
be around for all of training camp and
and oh by the way it can still make you
extremely sick or worse another one from
a red zone i need to wrap this up we've
been going a long time
will roger goodell attend a game and
take a knee this year i don't know that
he will
i don't know that he even fits within
the classification of the tier one
people who are going to be allowed on
the sidelines during a game
look i think what the nfl is going to do
they're going to support the players
to an extent
the owners have still yet to come out
and say they support the players see the
owners are trying to play nice with the
president especially the owners who
support the president and people like
greg popovich
and
who else made this point there was a
player who made this point recently
that that it's michael bennett who
you know have said
it's it's hard to reconcile supporting
the players
and their
interest in protesting during the anthem
and also supporting the president when
the president has made it clear that he
is
strongly and vehemently opposed to
to any type of anthem protest
so
i think the league is going to try to
find a way not necessarily to have a
middle ground but they're going to try
to find ways to not unnecessarily and
gratuitously agitate the president there
are going to be plenty of things the
president won't like
but they're not going to go out of their
way to make him notice and i think if
the commissioner takes a knee
that's one of those things that is going
to
attract the attention the wrath and the
venom of the president you know there
have been recent
developments that the president didn't
notice j.j watt baker mayfield saying
they're going to take a knee not a peep
from the president bill o'brien coach of
the texans saying he's going to kneel
during the anthem not a peep from the
president so i think you know i think i
believe the commissioner when he says
they're not going to let the criticism
from the president
deter them but i don't think they're
going to go out of the way
to pick a fight with the president
they're going to ignore
the attacks they're not going to engage
him and they're going to hope that he
doesn't notice everything that could
cause him to go to twitter and rally the
base on the issue of protests during the
anthem
all right uh
i need to wrap this up there's still
several more questions here
um cz wald in the richard brooks
let me do this in the ray sharp brook
situation where do you stand on the
police responsibility for society and
the greater good it is awful that life
was lost truly where is the line police
were assaulted and a weapon was stolen
what about the police responsibility to
the public look
i i do not believe
that rachard brooks was presenting
an immediate threat to the life of
either of those officers or anyone else
around he was drunk he resisted arrest
which he shouldn't have done first of
all he shouldn't have been behind the
wheel of a car while drunk and he was
going to face the consequences for that
he shouldn't have resisted arrest
and he would have faced the consequences
for that he shouldn't have resisted
arrest with violence that's a felony and
he should have faced the consequences
for that he shouldn't have taken the
taser and run away he shouldn't have
done that and he would have and should
have faced the consequences for that
but nothing that he did
justified the police officer taking on
the role of judge jury
executioner with no opportunity for any
type of a reprieve from the governor
immediately carrying out the sentence
with
a line of cars
sitting in the wendy's drive-thru
right next to where all of this was
playing out and no by the way a bullet
hole
in one of those other cars
rachar brooks was not a threat to the
life
of either of those officers or anyone
else
they knew where he lived they had his id
as someone on msnbc said the other night
it's not like a helicopter was going to
emerge and take him to kathmandu
this isn't a serial killer on his way to
his next victim this is a guy who was
drunk enough to fall asleep in the
drive-through line at wendy's he faced
criminal consequences for his behavior
but he did not deserve to die
and the use of deadly force in that
setting was reckless and unjustified and
i've heard people say well that's
standard operating procedure well you
know what the procedure needs to change
the procedure needs to change
the use of deadly force should be the
absolute last resort that is used by
police officers that gun should be the
last thing that comes out of the holster
and it should only happen when that
person is presenting an immediate risk
to the life
of the police officer or someone else
now
if ray sharp brooks had grabbed a gun
and taken off
then
the shots need to be fired if he's
pointing a gun
if he's pointing at taser
and and i saw i don't know whether it
was one of the lawyers or someone from
the police union
well they shot him in the only area of
his body that presented himself at the
time his back
and i didn't know where to laugh or cry
when i saw that
they shot him in the back
when you shoot someone in the back who
is running away from you what risk are
they presenting to you at that time
now and maybe you pulled out the gun
when he was turning to you
with the taser maybe that's when you
pull out the gun
but when he turns his back
why are you pulling the trigger when he
turns his back
and if you're not someone who can be
trusted in that moment to turn off
whatever it is inside of you that has
taken over
whether it's ego because you got punched
by this guy
whether it's adrenaline
because what was a very innocuous police
interaction all of a sudden turned
into something that wasn't innocuous
whatever it is
that kept that person from recognizing
i should not pull the trigger and shoot
this man in his back while he's running
away
whatever that was it shows that the
person isn't fit to be a police officer
it shows that the person isn't fit to be
carrying a gun
and like so many other things in today's
society
uh
it's amazing that there are
two sides to this how can there be two
sides to every issue how can that be
wha
i mean people think the earth is flat
people think the moon landing was fake
people think every like there is there
is not universal agreement on anything
how can that be
how can you watch the video
of
rachar brooks being shot and killed and
think that was an appropriate use of
deadly force how can how can you how can
you get your brain to the point where
the guy gets shot in the back and that's
okay when he was pointing a taser not a
gun i guess even if he had an actual gun
by the time he's turned and running
you pull the gun and you hold it on him
and then if he turns back with the gun
then you shoot him but he's running away
he's running away
so
i i look
and we spent a lot of time thinking
about these things writing about these
things and talking about these things
because there is a clear overlap right
now to the national football league
because the national football league is
such an important part of our public
life and the players have a voice and
they're exercising that voice and the
coaches have a voice and they're
exercising that voice the owners
aren't doing much and i hope at some
point they will
but uh
you know these are very very
uncertain times
there are times on one hand of hope but
on the other hand
it's disheartening
it's disheartening to see how many
people just refuse to accept
that
equality is something we should aspire
for i i don't i don't get it can someone
explain to me
what maybe maybe instead of
maybe instead
of and it's very worthwhile
to study and understand why it is that
black americans feel like
they have been the targets of
discrimination from the system for years
and it's important i'm not saying
instead of how about in addition to that
is there some way maybe i need to
interview somebody who just flat out
just fl like but that's the thing
they'll never admit it
they'll throw out all these roadblocks
and hurdles
to the points that we're making
and like i said earlier they'll move the
goalpost to something else i just i
don't understand what the opposition is
it
caller murray explained it so well on
wednesday this is a matter of right and
wrong this is a matter of equality or
inequality why is anyone taking a stand
against equality why is anyone taking a
stand against change that will finally
guarantee for all americans the promise
that is america the promise that was
vested for all americans on july 4 1776.
i don't get it
let me see if there's anything else here
all right uh
trying to find one more before we wrap
this up
brian stanley at donkey 170. with the
university of texas news 13 positive
tests it's obvious the nfl will face
consistent positive results unless it's
in a bubble how will they react
i personally see a it's just the flu
strategy coming back look i don't know
that that's what's going to come back
the bottom line is
if someone's positive even if they're
asymptomatic if they test positive
they're not going to be allowed to play
and
i guess all they could really do is just
only test when someone has symptoms
that's the only way around this
just go ahead and let it like the sweden
approach let it wash through the nfl
population and just assume that a lot of
guys are going to be positive and only
worry about it when someone has the
symptoms that's all they could do
other than what they are doing which is
have an aggressive testing protocol and
if someone is positive they're not
allowed onto a practice field onto a
onto a game field into a locker room
anywhere around any other players that's
the only responsible thing to do so the
question becomes at what point do we
recognize there's just no way to do this
and maybe that's where this is headed
maybe that's where it's headed with
college football because there's too
many programs too many players too many
variables too much stuff it's too hard
to get 20 year olds 19 year olds 18 year
olds to do what they're supposed to do
maybe the only hope is 32 nfl teams
where it is drilled into their brains
what they need to do when they're away
from the facility and they fully buy in
for four months and there's
accountability within the team the tom
brady's of the world making sure that
their teammates aren't doing stupid
things that would expose them to the
virus maybe that's the only hope and
i'll come back to something i was
talking about yesterday the fact that
espn reportedly is withholding naming a
monday night football broadcast team
because if there's no college football
this fall they want it to be chris
fowler and kirk herb street the fact
that espn has that plan tells me
espn knows something the rest of us
don't
and it tells me
that somewhere within the corridors at
the campus in bristol someone has made
the conclusion
they think there's a pretty good chance
there isn't going to be college football
but there will be nfl football and you
know what
you know i went for a stretch thinking
it's going to be difficult to have any
football then i went through a stretch
thinking the nfl will pull it off
because there's too much money involved
not to pull it off it's going to be too
hard for college to pull it off and then
i went through a stretch thinking hey
they're all gonna they're just gonna be
football and now i'm starting to swing
back toward
there may not be college football
but maybe there will be pro football
and if that's the case remember we spent
time talking about well
what would the nfl do will they play
games on saturdays they should
they should play games on saturdays in
the same three windows that we see on
sundays and they should maybe drop a
game on friday nights
but uh
i'm starting to think that's where this
is headed nobody knows where it's headed
the nfl claims it has a plan for
everything i don't know what the details
are do they know what the details are
how buttoned up are the plans is the nfl
pa on board are the coaches on board
will everyone do what they need to do a
lot of questions to be resolved and
we're going to be here every step of the
way i very much want trust me i want
there to be a football season
and i want the nfl to handle things in a
way that ensures there will be a
football season a lengthy pftpm has come
to a conclusion big cat joins me
tomorrow for pft live we have coverage
around the clock of all things nfl at
profootballtalk.com even in this slow
time which is not as slow as i thought
it was going to be because there are
plenty of issues to be discussed and
dissected in the nfl and we will do that
all the time all day every day at
profotballtalk.com we'll see you on
friday morning and we'll see you all day
every day at
profootballtalk.com have a great day
thanks for some of your time we'll see
you the next time we do pftp